scores of missiles again launched
against Ukraine the question is whether
this is part of a new Russian offensive
but there seem to be two things
happening here we'll take you through it
first of all we saw missile attacks
multiple missile attacks on Kiev karkov
zapparigia these are cities far away
from Russian control what were they
targeting well a familiar pattern uh
which we're all getting used to really
this shows a hydroelectric station smoke
coming out of it how do we know where
that is well just look at that rather
distinctive shape building bear in mind
the body of water the shape of that
building and we can try and match that
to satellite imagery
so this is what we see on satellites you
can see the power plant up here body of
water it's looking like a convincing
match but if we go into street view down
here just to have a look around at the
surroundings uh we can make absolutely
sure we're in the right place because
again there are so many claims and
counter claims in this war we want to
make sure that we know exactly what's
happening and if we take you around here
you can see that very distinctive
building with that bell shaped down so
we're happy this is aborigia and that
what seems to be happening in that area
of the country but something else uh in
the east of the country in the
donbastian yes and luhansk will take you
in a bit closer we've been talking about
this for a long time solidar obviously
captured by the Russians the fierce
fighting around Bachmann this is what
the situation looked like a week ago in
Bangor the red areas is definite Russian
control and this is what they've taken
in the meantime you can see that's not a
huge amount but it is contributing to
the sense of encirclement we're seeing
Russian positions a lot further on now
again this is all contested this is one
of those videos that we've found
verified you can see here just pause it
help you make it out a bit better those
are two Russian soldiers along with
their colleagues over there trying to
get into a building for cover this is
from the Ukrainian military and you'll
see what they do next
um they find that building they're
targeting it with shelling so this is
still deeply contested even as Russia
seems to be coming around the question
then becomes well if Batman does fall
whether that's because an evacuation
does Russia push on to chromatous and
slavians these are more important cities
strategically but they are better
defended they have very strong defensive
lines so even if Batman does go and it's
probably not worth that much in the
grand scheme apart from the symbolic
victory of course it is not going to be
a quick march to those two cities this
is going to be another long bloody slog